ich habe einen coolen prank vorbereitet
aber erstmal müssen wir dann ein
bisschen ablenken Leute wir kommentieren
sich zu meiner Hose ich wusste nicht
dass sie so durchsichtig ist warum bald
Tür aufgemacht und alles schreiben mir
ist irgendwie voll durchsichtig Stimme
normal auf nein
Problem sonst prank sagt Sandy mal dass
es wirklich nicht klar geht gerade mit
dem Hals mach mal die Tür zu
kannst du mal mit deinem Boot kommen
zwei Glocken ja okay komm dann müssen
wir uns jetzt auf dem Weg machen hast du
zwei Glocken
kannst Du mir gegeben mein Bruder weil
ich meine eigenen meine Bruder
vom neuen Update entdecken Sandy weißt
du was im neuen Update mit dazu kam
McDonald's
Pläne gefallen ich würde so gern einmal
heute im Stream versuchen gegen den
Endlevel zu streamen Luca ja wir müssen
es demnächst mal angehen gegen den
Enderdrachen meinst du mach hingehen
oder wie braucht ein bisschen
Vorbereitung aber das können wir in
einem Stream vielleicht schaffen es wird
tatsächlich auch bald oder was heißt
bald in Richtung Herbst Plan ich gerade
neues Minecraft Projekt kommen in
richtig richtig cooles mal wieder ihr
wisst ja dass ich damit ich will keine
normalen Minecraft machen Staffel 1 aber
auf seiner kleinen Insel Staffel 2 mit
diesen ganzen Mods Staffel 3 wenn man
wieder Skyblock und Staffel 4 sehr sehr
wild sehr schön wir gehen hier rein
okay
ja komm einmal gucken
ne
oh nee
verpiss Dich Sandra hast du du bist
jetzt auch mit dem mittlerweile ein
bisschen deeper drin in der ganzen
Minecraft Materie hast du hier heute ein
prank geplant an mich weil ich no joke
ich will mich nur auf den Pferdestall
konzentrieren
ich werde sie Pranken okay gut ich auch
nicht wenn die bald geht ja selber vs
white los ne die sind ja Kanada da oben
wir sind ja leider nicht mit dabei wir
haben uns auch einfach nicht beworben
Ilja hat uns gefragt ob wir wollen wir
haben gesagt ja und dann haben wir nie
eine Bewerbung abgeschickt Videos wo man
sich bewerben richtig Video hochladen
ganz ehrlich vielleicht besser so weil
ich glaube wir beide wir werden wirklich
die ersten die abgekackt werden da ich
glaube es werden definitiv mit Abstand
das lustigste Duo gewesen aber ich
glaube wirklich wir werden als erstes
rausgeflogen weil du mich irgendwie
gegessen hättest oder so wo bist denn du
Sandy
[Musik]
auf dem Baum ja ja
guck mal ich baue mich jetzt extrem hoch
dann siehst du mich wieder
Leute habt ihr euer Abi bestanden
wichtigere Frage oh mein gott hat jemand
sich gepackt wenn ja würde ich nicht
schlecht ich habe es auch nicht gepackt
jemand die lustigste em der Welt
geschrieben ich habe die Luca auch
gezeigt ihr schreibt sie jemand hell
Sandra du bist voll mein Vorbild äh will
jetzt wegen dir auch Abi abbrechen nicht
so nicht absolute Ehrenmann bist du
komplett verloren wo bist du denn schon
wieder wie können wir nämlich dann immer
verlieren nein andere Richtung Event in
Düsseldorf auf einer Party am Flughafen
habe ich auch wieder so eine Mutter
angesprochen meinte nur sehr das ist
echt super was ihr macht auch das sind
Vorbild seid und so das ist wichtig dass
die Kinder sowas haben bist du in der
wir wieso Podcast also ich denke so oder
wir reden über saufen dass wir wieder
Schwachsinn gemacht haben du hast kein
Abi ja danke stimmt kein Abi zu haben
vor 15 Jahren hätte ich gesagt ja
mittlerweile mit den ganzen neuen
Berufen und alles mögliche würde ich
sagen ist ein Vorteil aber es ist kein
Nachteil auch wenn du Ausbildung
geschafft hast hast ja auch automatisch
Fachabitur studieren und so deine Nase
war letztens so extrem weiß in einem
Video ja das ist mir auch aufgefallen
Nachrichten bekommen von wegen hä hast
du geguckt leute das ist Nivea Creme
gewesen in meiner Nase
Pferdestall ja bevor wir uns allerdings
um den Pferdestall kümmern werde ich
jetzt den
[Musik]
vorbereiten
ich habe mir heftig geiles Projekt für
uns okay wir schnappen uns Fahrräder und
fahren damit versuchen damit irgendwie
ins Ausland sofort in eine geile Stadt
nein aber was hältst du davon wenn wir
wirklich im Spätsommer zu zweit so eine
Tour machen ey ich habe dir gesagt ich
bin direkt dabei dann müssen wir jetzt
einfach das Plan Leute habt ihr da Bock
drauf das Handy und ich im Spätsommer
Sonne also im Herbst oder so eine Tour
machen mit dem Auto mit so einem oder so
schreibt sie unten in die Kommentare
was
unsere unsere Stadt wird angegriffen
komm sofort ich habe kein Wort oh mein
Gott ach so oh mein Gott ich dachte
irgendwas brennt
einfach die jetzt töten ne
okay Luca ausrüsten wir brauchen stechen
und jetzt regnet es auch noch eh es ist
doch nicht wahr aber ich glaube das
einzige weil oben kommt doch sonst immer
so ein Strich oder ach drohendes Unheil
ach so nee kommt gar kein Überfall Sandy
das ist nur ähm wenn wir im Dorf sind
das heißt wenn ich jetzt einen du musst
auch einmal Milch trinken hier ich gebe
dir ein Komma zu mir wenn wir beide
einmal Milch trinken dann geht das weg
das äh lindert ja die Effekte
kommst du zu mir
aber nicht trinken also während Sandy
sich da oben jetzt gerade noch um ihr
Haus kümmert werde ich den prank
vorbereiten denn ich habe einen Big boat
prank geplant ich werde Dispenser
hinsetzen ich werde
ihr werdet schon sehen ich werde euch
das zeigen ich möchte mich kurz und
dreht noch mal ein paar Subs Vorsicht
okay so machen wir nicht denn wir werden
den prank vorbereiten wir mussen werfen
das Fenster da müssen wir zwei von denen
dran und den hier müssen wir noch mal
kurz abbauen und anders wieder hinsetzen
schon nee
hier
hört ihr das an
jetzt geht's los
so Leute ich habe das Handy noch mal
kurz gemutet wir bauen das jetzt alles
wieder ab dürfen das Boot da unten nicht
bewegen weil das sind jetzt hier ganz
ganz viele Boote deswegen sage ich jetzt
Sandy a sandy lass mal noch mal kurz mit
dem Boot losfahren wir müssen noch mal
in die andere Richtung jetzt schauen
nach einem Dorf wir müssen trotz oh mein
Gott der Frosch hat nicht so erschrocken
gerade äh wir müssen trotzdem noch mal
eben weiter suchen nach Glocken gib mir
mal kurz eine Minute ich bau mal kurz
mein Vordach fertig ja alles gut eine
Ewigkeit später
die Glocke holen weil ich brauche jetzt
endlich die Sachen für die ganzen ja wir
können jetzt direkt losfahren
du ich muss noch ein bisschen auf Dings
gucken
einfach in die Richtung
[Musik]
der war schon gut muss man sagen also
mit der Vorbereitung und allem ich habe
wirklich du siehst das dann im Youtube
Video aber ich habe wirklich lange
gebraucht um die ganzen Dispenser den
ganzen Boote zu machen und so das war
jetzt nicht nur komme ich mal kurz
irgendwo runter 11 von 10 Jahren Leute
[Musik]